Olha só, um estudo chinês acabou de
virar de cabeça para baixo tudo que a
gente sabia sobre Paxon. Os
pesquisadores descobriram que aquela
proteína que causa a doença alfaucleína
pode estar se acumulando primeiro nos
rins e só depois migrar pro cérebro.
Pois é, analisaram o paciente com Paxon
e viram essa proteína normal nos rins em
quase todos os casos. Veja bem, isso é
revolucionário porque significa que a
doença pode estar silenciosamente se
desenvolvendo anos antes dos tremores
aparecerem. É como se o rim fosse o
alarme de incêndio que ninguém está
ouvindo. E o mais impressionante,
pessoas com doença renal crônica também
tinham essa proteína acumulada, mesmo
sem sintomas neurológicos ainda. Então
fica a dica, cuide dos seus rins como se
o seu cérebro dependesse disso, porque
talvez dependa mesmo